>> John Haskell:
Members of Congress
and distinguished guests,
welcome, to the Library
of Congress and the 8th
Henry A. Kissinger lecture.
I'm John Haskell, director
of the Kluge Center
here at the library.
The Kissinger program is made
possible by generous donations
of the friends and
admirers of Dr. Kissinger
who was the 56th Secretary
of State of the United States
and a recipient of
the Nobel Peace Prize.
Before we move on, on behalf
of all of us at the library,
we join America in
mourning the passing
of former president
George H.W. Bush.
The Kissinger program
celebrates statesmanship
and foreign policy, President
Bush's legacy of commitment
to global diplomacy
is in keeping
with exactly that tradition.
We all wish the extended
Bush family
and as many close friends the
best in this difficult time.
In a similar vein, we mourn
the passing last month
of Dr. James Billington, the
13th librarian of Congress.
The Kissinger program is one
of his many legacies here
at his distinguished
career at the library,
which spanned 28 years.
The Kissinger lecture has been
delivered by heads of state,
including former Prime Minister
Tony Blair, former president
of Mexico, Filipe Calderon,
former president of Brazil,
Fernando Enrique
Cardoso, former president
of the French Republic
Valery Giscard d'Estaing,
as well as former United
States Secretaries of State,
James Baker, George Schultz,
and Dr. Kissinger, himself.
As is customary, tonight's
program will include an address
by our Kissinger lecturer,
Madame Christine Lagarde,
followed by a conversation
with Margaret Brennan,
CBS News senior foreign
affairs correspondent and host
of Face of the Nation.
At this time, it is
my distinct pleasure
to introduce Dr. Carla Hayden,
the 14th librarian of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Carla Hayden: Good
evening, Madame Lagarde,
members of Congress, and
distinguished guests.
We are deeply honored to
welcome to the Library
of Congress tonight Christine
Lagarde, managing director
of the International
Monetary Fund.
As you can see, we
are in the great hall
of the library's Thomas
Jefferson building,
surrounded by visual art,
symbolizing the progress
of civilization and the
traditions of knowledge
and learning, a most
fitting venue
for the 8th Kissinger lecture.
Madame Christine Lagarde is a
distinguished public servant
with deep knowledge of
the world's economy,
and the ways financial
architecture can shape the lives
of individuals in
countries around the globe.
Among her many other high
ranking points and posts
in government and the
private sector, in June 2007,
she became the first woman
to hold the post of finance
and economy minister
of a G7 country.
Later, as chairman of the G20,
she set in motion a wide
ranging agenda on the reform
of international
monetary systems.
And on July 5th, 2011,
Ms. Lagarde became the 11th
managing director of the IMF
and the first woman
to hold that position.
And on February 19th, 2016, the
IMF executive board selected her
to serve as managing director
for a second five year term.
She has tackled some of the most
challenging financial issues
related to European integration,
international trade,
and the development of
global economic governance.
However, I am excited
to be the person
that will deliver breaking news.
The room just got
a little quieter.
[Laughter].
Well, today, Forbes released
its 100 Most Powerful Women
in the World and Madame
Christine Lagarde was voted the
third most powerful
woman in the world.
[ Applause ]
So ladies and gentleman,
please join me
in welcoming Ms.
Christine Lagarde.
[ Applause ]
>> Christine Lagarde: Thank
you, very much, Dr. Hayden,
dear Carla, for this generous
and brief introduction.
They are the best.
I'm so happy to see many
of you here, my friends,
and very much looking forward to
the discussion that we will have
after these remarks
with Margaret Brennan.
And thank you also, Mr.
Haskell, for the warm welcome
that you've extended
to all of us.
He could not be here tonight
but I had a conversation
with him just before arriving
at this beautiful Library
of Congress and Henry
Kissinger was delighted
that we were gathering tonight
and he has asked me to express
to all of you his best wishes
and very strong support
for continuing the lecture
that he started back in 2001.
I would also like
to indicate myself
that somebody else is very
much in our thoughts tonight.
And that is, obviously, former
President George H.W. Bush
and all his family members.
We all mourn his passing, many
others are trying to enter
into the rotunda as we speak.
And we celebrate
the arc of his life.
The pilot who bravely fought
in World War II, the president
who helped heal division after
the cold war, and the statesman
who believed in the power of
international cooperation.
I hope to honor his
spirit tonight.
And I was privileged
to meet him recently
on several occasions
up in Maine.
And I could appreciate
what a kind,
generous, and noble man he was.
So tonight -- tonight
is December 4th.
It's actually an important
date for a particularly reason
that I will not mention
to you now.
You'll have to wait until
the end of my remarks.
[Laughter].
And you're not allowed to look
at your cell phone, please.
[Laughter].
No. I have to confess
something here.
When I walked into
the great hall
and was given a lovely private
tour by you, Dr. Hayden,
three thoughts crossed my mind.
The first one was, this young
French student who was studying
for her political science
dissertation back 42 years ago,
and has spent quite a little bit
of time, in the reading room,
thanks to the courtesy of
the Library of Congress,
I was able to better
research the work that I did
on Ralph Nader and the American
consumerism of those days.
Thank you.
I am in your debt.
The second person whom I
thought about was my son,
who is a young architect.
He would love this place.
He would love it.
The space, the height,
the creativity.
And the third thought I had
was about my country, France.
And maybe another
country, actually,
that I was just visiting a
couple of days, Argentina.
Now why is that?
Well, when this structure
was completed in 1897,
the chief engineer remarked, I
quote, "that the Palais Garnier,
the Paris Opera House,
was the prime suggestion
for the new Library
of Congress."
That makes sense, actually.
Because the Paris Opera House
was completed 20 years earlier
in 1875.
Now, I think the French may
have borrowed a little bit
from others.
Because the Teatro Colón
in Buenos Aires was,
itself, finished in 1857.
And if you look at these
three buildings, well,
it tells you something.
First of all, that valuable
intellectual property was
of great interest across
borders, even back then,
at least among architects
who happily borrowed
from each other,
learned from each other,
became inspired as a result.
Second, it reminds us
that they understood
that building something
lasting means linking the solid
foundations of the past with
the spark of imagination.
You can't just copycat.
That kind of creativity
and long-term vision rooted
in history and informed by
our successes and failures
from the past is my
theme for this evening.
First, where have we been?
How has creativity
and international economy
cooperation helped bring more
prosperity and more
peace in the world?
And second, where can
we travel together?
How can creativity and informed
visionary thinking help adapt
the international system
to our current challenges?
So let me begin first with a
little bit of shared history
between the international
monetary fund
and the United States
over the last 75 years.
In the first half
of the 20th century,
the dominant economy [inaudible]
military powers used force
to assert their self-interests
at enormous costs in terms
of human life and
physical destruction.
The tragic results compelled
nations to find a better way.
It only took them two wars
and atrocities along the way.
But in 1944, they found it.
The United States emerged
as the major global power
and did something unprecedented.
Informed by the devastating,
ultimate outcome
of the Versailles Treaty
at the end of World War I,
for which we just celebrated
the 100-anniversary,
the United States
decided to use its power
in the service of cooperation.
It was an experiment that
would shape our modern world.
And in his inaugural
lecture in 2001,
Dr. Kissinger called
the innovations
of the post war period, I quote,
"a great burst of creativity
that brought security
to the world."
How did the U.S. do it?
Out of generosity?
Yes. With consideration
to their self interests?
Yes. And with a little help
from some of their friends.
Let us look at that turning
point of 75 years ago
and think first of the creation
of the Breton Wood
system, itself.
The principle architects,
John Maynard Keynes of the U.K
and Harry Dexter White of the
U.S. were deeply influenced
by the period between
the two wars.
They witnessed a
moment in history
when flawed domestic policies
poisoned international
relationships, which
themselves were built
on troubled foundations.
Treaty of Versailles.
The result was protectionism
and competitive currency
devaluations,
imploding world trade
deepened the Great Depression
and caused massive economic,
financial, and social upheaval.
Ultimately, these pressures
gave rise to nationalist
and populist movements and
eventually catastrophe.
Emerging from the second
world war, the U.S.
and some other 40 countries
gathered in Bretton Woods,
New Hampshire, and decided
to create the International
Monetary Fund
and the World Bank.
They tasked the fund with
three critical missions,
promoting international
monetary cooperation,
supporting the expansion of
trade and economic growth,
and discouraging policies
that would harm prosperity.
It was revolutionary.
It was visionary.
And guess what?
It worked.
From the very beginning, the IMF
held countries address major new
challenges through
collaboration.
Complimenting the marshal plan,
we at the IMF helped Europe
rebuild from the rubble of war.
Our loans gave countries
breathing space
to stabilize their
economies in difficult time
and implement policies
to promote growth.
It's a mission that we
continue to this day,
as you may have recently seen in
countries like Argentina, Egypt,
Ukraine and many others.
The genius of the collaborative
system that they invented was
that it was designed
to adapt and change.
And in the early '70s,
that change arrived.
Some of you might remember
that speech, a landmark speech.
The challenge of peace.
President Nixon suspended the
U.S. dollars convertibility
into gold.
And that decision
shocked the world
and forced a year-long
negotiation that led
to the modern floating
exchange rate structure,
away from the fixed gold
reference structure moving
into floating exchange
rate structure.
A system that is
still today in place
in many corners of the world.
But at the time, some thought
that this particular change
would mean the end of the IMF.
But all our members at the time,
including the United States knew
that the goal of stability
and prosperity extended well
beyond fixed exchange rates.
They recognized the benefits
of a global financial
[inaudible] fighter
that could help countries
in times of need.
They built on what worked,
changed what did not,
and they adapted.
And we moved on,
1973, the oil crisis.
The IMF created new tools
to help countries facing
an energy emergency in line
with the funds role
to help smooth shocks
and prevent harmful spillovers.
As a debt crisis hit lots
in America in the '80s,
the IMF with creative
ideas and support
from the United States
stepped in to calm the waters.
And after the fall
of the Berlin Wall,
we took on a new challenge,
which was helping the former
Soviet Union block nations
transform themselves
from centrally planned
to free market economies.
In the 1990s, the fund
assisted countries
in overcoming first
the Mexican peso crisis
and then the Asian
financial crisis.
And throughout all
these challenges,
we continue to help
countries around the world
with the economic fundamentals.
Their fiscal, monetary,
and exchange rate policies
and with steps to build
stronger economic institutions.
Because without that
macroeconomic stability growth
cannot prosper.
These efforts enabled better
policies that opened markets,
bolstered trade, created jobs,
and unleashed economic
potential.
And then came 2008 and
the financial crisis,
the global financial crisis.
Most of the other crisis that
I have referred to applied
to particular regions.
This one was the first of
a completely global nature.
The ensuing great
recession reminded us
that international cooperation
was essential not optional
and as the French finance
minister at the time,
I certainly was [inaudible]
in that exercise.
All G20 nations and the Federal
Reserve took extraordinary steps
to save the system.
As veterans when we
sort of come together,
we just wonder how we did it?
And how much we transgressed and
had to violate many principles
and rules and just reinvent.
But at the time, the IMF
deployed its own fire power
committing over $500 billion to
help secure the global economy.
And in the decade since
the 2008 financial crisis,
we supported economic
programs in 90 countries
and adopted our lending
instruments,
including zero interest loans,
to help low-income countries.
But the global economy did
not only need liquidity
and stimulus, it also needed
to reform its financial
architecture.
And we worked with
our membership
to build a stronger
financial sector
so that we could together
limit the consequences
of what will be one
day the next crisis.
So we learned from the past.
We got creative and we
changed for the better.
And none of that -- none of
that would have been possible
without the United States.
This country challenged the
international economy corridor
when it needed challenging.
It forged compromise when
compromise was necessary.
Why? Why did it do all that?
Benevolence?
It does so because a stronger
and more stable world paid
dividends for the United States.
It enabled the U.S. to enjoy
some of the longest runs
of sustained economic growth
the modern world has ever known.
Since that meeting at Bretton
Woods nearly 75 years ago real
U.S. GDP increased
by a factor of eight.
And the average Americans
real income has quadrupled.
And this success did not come
at the expense of other nations.
On the contrary, this country's
collaborative leadership paved
the way, not only for decades
of opportunities here in America
but also for growth that
spread across the world.
Now, today that landscape
is shifting again.
And part of this change
is driven by geopolitics
and the shift in some economic
power from west to east.
Part of it by the rise
of non state actors including
multi-national organizations
and corporates.
Part of it is driven
by technology
and the rapid acceleration
of everything in our lives.
As I'm sure you know,
Dr. Hayden,
90 percent of the world's
data was created just
over the last two years.
Now, I have to say as a daughter
of two classics professors,
I know my parents
would have found
that very, very depressing.
[Laughter].
But the truth is that everything
moves faster, information,
money, disease, you name it.
And this transformation can
bring enormous opportunities
but they can also
create massive risks.
Why is that?
Because more than every before
at least as was demonstrated
in 2008, what happens one nation
is going to impact all nations.
From weapons of mass
destruction to cybersecurity
to the interconnected
financial system,
many of our current
challenges recognize no borders.
So when support
for international
cooperation falters,
we must remember the
lessons the United States
and her allies taught the
world over the last 75 years.
It's a big lesson.
Solidarity is self interest.
And that principle endures
in our changing world.
Our challenge now is to
yet again adapt and reform.
So I believe that
this year, 2019,
can be another turning
point in our journey.
A moment when the world delivers
a new burst of creativity
in solving our shared
challenges.
Actually there's something
up there that you can't see
but from which we
can draw inspiration.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
But it's something like,
they build too low those
who build beneath the stars.
It's written up there.
Imagine what the world
could be if we were
to build beneath the
stars, the [inaudible],
as I call it, or
the age of anger.
Let's imagine the age of anger.
By 2040, inequality could exceed
the levels of the gilded age.
Strong tech monopolice
and weak governments
with ineffective domestic
policies could make it
impossible for start ups and
entrepreneurs to succeed.
Health breakthroughs could allow
the richest to live past 120,
while millions of
others would suffer
from extreme poverty
and disease.
Social media would bombard
the left behind population
and [inaudible] the disparity
between their reality
and the possibility
of a better life
and the aspiration gap would
fuel resentment and anger.
Trust between nations
would break down.
The world would be more
interconnected digitally
but less connected
in every other way.
International cooperation
for the benefit
of all would be a concept
best studied in libraries,
like this one, but rarely
practiced on the world stage due
to the supremacy of
national interest
and a singular focus
on domestic policies.
To borrow from Dr. Kissinger's
world order we might be,
I quote, "facing a period
in which forces beyond
the restraints
of any order determine
the future."
That is a very dystopian
scenario.
Isn't it? Not one that we
designed and certainly not one
that I believe can, and
should be, our destiny.
Neither does Dr.
Kissinger, for that matter.
We have overcome
existential threats before
and we can do so again.
Think of the world.
If we make 2019 the start
of a different kind of A-I.
Everybody thinks, oh,
she's going to talk
about artificial intelligence.
No. Age of ingenuity.
This would be a future fueled
by creativity and cooperation.
Okay, 2040.
I'm in a new scenario now.
We would see flourishing
economies predominantly running
on renewable energy.
Women would be fully empowered
in the workforce proving
to be an economic and
social game changer.
New pension systems
and healthcare portability would
reflect the changing nature
of work in the digital economy.
Corporation would embrace
social responsibility as part
of their business model
because they would be rated
on that basis as well.
Technology called
wizardry could save lives
and create millions of jobs.
We would see an end to mass
migration, trade would expand
across the world and
peaceful coexistence
between nations would prevail.
Am I being too optimistic?
Of course.
You know the difference between
the optimist and the pessimist?
They're both wrong but
the optimist is happier.
[Laughter].
So I have to be optimistic.
Because I'm thinking about the
world my grown children will
enter it.
But it presents us with a
fundamental choice, stand still
and watch discord and discontent
bubble over into conflict.
Or, move forward, reimagine
the way nations work together
and build prosperity and peace.
Okay, nice words.
What does it mean in practice?
It means countries working
together to put people,
all people, at the
center of all our efforts.
Focusing on real results
to improve their lives.
It also means governments
and institutions being more
transparent and accountable,
which includes listening
to more diverse voices.
It means ensuring
that economic benefits
of globalizations are shared
by many, not just a few.
I call that the new
multilateralism
[assumed spelling].
You might just call
it common sense,
if that word suits you better.
But let me be very clear here.
Good international cooperation
is never going to substitute
for good domestic policy.
And of course, individual
countries have the
responsibility for the well
being of their citizens.
In fact, strong domestic
policies can form the foundation
for effective international
cooperation
and in our modern world,
there are some issues
that can only be addressed
through international
cooperation.
I want to discuss
four such issues.
I promise I'll be brief
on each of the four.
But I think they're
all important.
And to be successful in
delivering on those four,
we will need creativity and
we will need cooperation.
Let me start with
those -- the first one.
First one is trade.
I've been saying
for some time now
that we need to fix the system.
More recently, I've
been urging countries
to actually de-escalate
trade [inaudible].
And it was encouraging to see
over the weekend
some progress made
at the G20 meeting
in Buenos Aires.
And we must continue
the de-escalation while
at the some time improving the
trading system for the future.
That would include eliminating
distortionary subsidies,
whichever form or
color they take,
but agreeing on what they are.
It would also mean protecting
intellectual properties rights
without stifling innovation and
getting rid of economic grants.
New trade agreements could
unleash the potential
of e-commerce and
trade in services.
And all of this is critical.
Not for the sake of trade,
although Montesquieu
would argue with me.
And he would say, where there
is trade there is good manners.
Is he right?
Montesquieu is always right.
No, it's critical because
trade lifts productivity.
Trade accelerates innovation.
And we need both.
Second issue where we
need more cooperation is
international taxation.
Companies now have
world-wide presence,
even when they're small.
In the old days,
you had to be one
of those top guns
to be international.
Now, very small companies can
be very international companies.
But governments have
not figured, yet,
a world wide answer to tax.
And right now, too many
tax dollars are left
on the table thanks
to tax optimization
and the bad kind of creativity.
So countries need to
work closely together
to collect what is
owed, where it's owed,
and avoid a race
tax to the bottom.
They can close the
loopholes that lead
to what is called base
erosion and profit shifting.
We are working with our partners
so that our members can
share best practices
and devise regulation
for digital economy
in which many companies have
no single established based
of operation, and
yet they do operate.
Why do we need this?
Why do we need revenue?
Because all countries should
be investing in their future.
And public and private funding
working together can strengthen
infrastructure, improve
education, and prepare all of us
to adjust to the
technical transformations
of at our doorsteps.
When the return on
those investments is
so far away it's very unlikely
that private sector alone
will actually invest.
My third issue is our climate.
From the recent major
hurricanes in the Caribbean
to the wild fires in California
to the sinking islands
of the Pacific, the
dangerous effects
of climate change are becoming
more tangible by the day.
A new U.S. government study
shows that the economic impact
from climate change could
significantly reduce America's
GDP in the coming decades.
The collaborative
agreement reached in Paris
in 2015 is probably the
best toolbox that we have
to start fixing the
planetary challenge
and move towards
zero carbon economy.
It also reflects some of
the ideas that I've tried
to highlight tonight,
creativity, visionary thinking,
and a global commitment
to the common good
that serves self interest.
This is as much of survival
for future generations.
Now I've mentioned three
issues, trade, tax, and climate.
And each of them is worthy of
their own Kissinger lecture.
But there is one issue that
I believe is the bedrock
for progress nearly
everywhere else.
And that is why the fourth
and final area I want
to discuss is good governance,
free from the shackles
of corruption.
The simple fact is that without
confidence in our institutions,
none of the change we
seek will be possible.
So let me focus on that briefly.
It's my four and last key point.
Why is corruption so corrosive?
Because when people start people
the economy no longer works
for them, society no
longer works for them,
they start disconnecting
from economy
and disconnecting from society.
Corruption saps economic
vitality
and siphons off desperately
need resources.
The money that is diverted
from education and health,
perpetuates inequality
and limits the possibility
of a better life.
Do you know what the annual
cost of bribery alone,
and corruption is more than
just bribery, but the cost
of bribery every year is 1.5 --
is estimated to be
at $1.5 trillion.
That's roughly 2
percent of global GDP.
Millennials feel
the problem acutely.
A recent survey of
global youth revealed
that young people identify
corruption, not jobs,
not better education,
but corruption
as the most pressing concern
in their own countries.
There is wisdom in this insight.
Because corruption is
the root cause of many
of economic injustices that many
of these young men
and women are facing.
And that is why,
with the support
of our entire membership
we are going
to scrutinize [inaudible]
the impact of corruption
on a country's macroeconomic
health.
So far we've done quite a bit
of work on anti-money laundering
and combating the
financing of terrorism.
We've done that.
We had 110 of our
country members.
But it's only a small part of
the wider work that is needed
to promote good governance.
Investing in institution
is indispensable
as is indispensable
[inaudible] to verify
that those institutions
actually deliver.
Because likewise,
corruption knows no border.
Think for a second, how Phintec
[assumed spelling] is changing
the economic game.
New innovations including
cryptocurrencies,
crypto-assets can be
used by cybercriminals
to funnel illicit
financial flows
and fund illegal activities
on a worldwide basis.
This is not one nation's problem
or within one nation's
power to resolve.
It can only be fixed through
cross border collaboration.
But it is fixable.
Because the same innovations
that create cross border
challenges can also be used
to help us fight back
through biometrics,
block chain, and more.
We can find creative
ways to build a better,
safer system for the long term.
Governments can and must work
with the world's best engineers
to build stronger
cybersecurity systems
that protect people's bank
account, their well being,
and even their hotel booking.
This is common good that
we must choose to support.
And if we take -- if we take
the challenge of corruption
as the model of cooperation
that we can actually implement,
it can be a model for the
other topics that I mentioned.
It can be the sign that
the brotherhood of man,
as Keynes called it,
is ready once again
to meet the call of history.
Except, by the way, that this
time women will play a role.
[ Applause ]
You should have seen
the photo of those
who created Bretton
Woods in 1944.
Forty-four men.
Full stop.
So I think it's by doing
that that we can
start restoring trust,
which is probably the
most precious and most
in demand commodity
in our society.
And this is how we begin to
adapt once more and reimagine
that international
cooperation that we need.
Now before I conclude, we
have one more thing to do.
I began my remark by mentioning
that December 4th was
an important date.
Now, there's one person
who is not allowed
to answer that question.
That's Mrs. Harmon,
who is the president
of the Woodrow Wilson Center.
Because on December 4,
1918, exactly 100 years ago
to this day, President Woodrow
Wilson set sail for France
to help negotiate what he
hoped would be a lasting peace.
He became the first U.S. --
the first sitting U.S.
President to travel to Europe.
And in some way -- some ways,
we can trace the origins
of modern creativity
and visionary thinking
in U.S. foreign policy
to this date.
It's also a humbling reminder
that our plans do not
always work out as intended.
But it is also a signal that we
must try and try and try again.
We must build on what
worked, change what does not,
and continually evolve, improve,
imagine a better
future for all people.
It was the vision that inspired
the leaders of this country
and it must be the mission that
will guide us in the days ahead.
Thank you, very much.
[ Applause ]
>> John Haskell: Thank
you, Madame Lagarde.
And without further delay I
want to welcome to the stage,
please join me in welcoming
to the stage Margaret Brennan,
the moderator of
CBS Face the Nation.
[ Applause ]
>> Margaret Brennan:
Thanks to all of you
and what a gorgeous venue
to have this conversation.
I'm privileged to have it today.
You know, your introduction,
you were --
it was pointed out that
you were named one --
the third most powerful, I
believe, between Theresa May
and Chancellor Merkel in
terms of most powerful women.
But I think the correction
that needs to be made is
that you're actually one of
the most powerful individuals
in the world, in terms of
some of the work you have done
to stabilize the global economy.
And that's why, I think,
you laying out your vision
as you had, there are a
lot of things that we want
to sort of break apart here.
Let's start off with
what's happening today.
You're seeing recession
fears come out once again.
It was a bad day in the markets.
There are some who looked
at what happened at the G20
and said, there wasn't progress.
You said you saw some.
How do you define some progress?
Where's the hope
that you're seeing?
>> Christine Lagarde: Well,
I might be a little bit bias
because I was also attending
previously the G7 leaders
meeting in Canada and
then the APEC meeting
in Papua, New Guinea.
And at the G7 there was
a reneged communicate
and at the APEC meeting there
was just no communicate.
People could not
agree on anything.
So the fact that leaders agreed
on a set of principles, issues,
points -- the fact
that there was
that was in a way reassuring.
So that's -- not any agreement.
I think it was probably not
as strong as some expected it
but it really touched
on many critical issues.
The language was not exactly
according to, sort of,
the example of communicate
drafting.
But there was, you know,
positive news coming
out of that.
There was clearly a
consensus around the fact
that trade was critically
important.
Trade had to be conducted
according to rules set
by an institution, the WTO
that had to be reformed.
It was a clear agreement on
the principle of reforms,
how it will be reformed is
going to be another matter and,
I think, it's not going
to take a few weeks
but probably more
months than weeks.
There was willingness to
engage on the part of all.
And Saturday night was
not such a bad outcome.
>> Margaret Brennan:
You mean, in the meeting
between Xi Jinping
and President?
>> Christine Lagarde: Yes.
Yes.
>> Margaret Brennan:
Ninety days?
Is that enough to come to
sort of trade agreement
between the two largest
economies in the world?
>> Christine Lagarde: Oh, I'm
not sure that's, you know,
the objective is
a trade agreement.
But if at least there
was significant progress
and a framework under which
they agreed to move forward
and to address some of
the key issues, I --
you know, I think what's
clearly important is to come
to an understanding
on both sides,
to agree on some key principles,
to have definitions of,
you know, what is a subsidy?
What warrants intellectual
property right of protection?
And what is a state
owned enterprise?
And so on and so forth.
So it is complicated.
And it is going to take time.
But the willingness of these
two presidents to move forward
and to agree to discuss
those issues, I think,
is compared with what we have
just gone through is progress.
Yes.
>> Margaret Brennan: So the
nervousness that we're seeing
in the markets, you're
saying, look, they're talking.
It is a positive.
>> Christine Lagarde: Yes, yes.
And, you know, we
can't just react
on a daily market variations.
These things take time.
Markets get jittery and
react sort of off the cuff
on the news of the day.
But I think those are
much longer term issues
that warrant time, thinking,
considerations, and you know,
it's also a clear shift
that we are seeing,
which is being acknowledged.
And will turn into, I
hope, some resolution.
>> Margaret Brennan: I
think it was in listening
to you sketch out, going back to
Bretton Woods, to the present,
I think it's a good
reminder to many people
that the U.S. was part and
parcel of creating many
of these international
institutions because now they,
in our daily political life,
are described or at least felt,
perceived by some, to be
against U.S. interests.
That is how some of the more
popular rhetoric has described
institutions like yours.
Today, in Europe, the Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo listed all
of what he felt were the flaws
of international organizations
and saying that even the IMF
has sort of failed to live
up to what it was meant to do,
which was to rebuild Europe.
He said now austerity measures,
the things that are doing,
are actually hurting the
world, not helping it.
What did you make of his speech?
And that description?
>> Christine Lagarde:
Well, first of all,
I did not read his
entire speech.
I saw bits and pieces
picked up and, you know,
I will very carefully
read his speech.
But, you know, I've heard
this austerity comment made
in many instances.
And --
When we are called upon
to help a country that is
in very dear financial
difficulties,
we have to restore stability.
We have to restore
public finance discipline.
We have to empower the
authorities with financing.
That's one thing that we do.
But we are also an instrument
of macroeconomic sanity.
Because if we're
called upon to act,
it's because there
was mismanagement.
There was poor public
finance organization.
There was poor monetary policy.
For multiple reasons, the
situation was not in order.
And we're trying not to bring
austerity but to bring order.
So that's number one.
Number two, if we did
not come in to help,
the situation would
be even worse.
Because what happens is when
a country calls for help,
we come in, we do expect
that public finances will be,
you know, re-disciplined,
reorganized,
and that stability will result.
At which point, investors
come in and say, okay,
now the situation is stabilized.
We can come back in
and we can invest.
So if we did not do that
they simply would not come
in at that point.
So I think it's -- we're not the
merchant of austerity, per se,
we are merchant of trust in
the stability of a system
that is needed in order
to attract investors,
generate growth, and, you
know, entail creation of jobs.
And that's -- we are
the enablers of that.
>> Margaret Brennan: You
called out for a kind
of collaborative
leadership, particularly
from the United States.
>> Christine Lagarde: Because
that is what has worked.
You know, when I look back
and I consider the history
of the United States role, it's
involvement, what has worked,
how has it worked for
this country and others.
That collaboration has
proven extremely efficient.
>> Margaret Brennan:
Well, the Secretary
of State today said the
administration is working
to refocus the IMF and WTO
to promote more prosperity,
halt lending tenations
[assumed spelling]
that can already access
global capital market
and reduce taxpayer
handouts to development banks
that could raise
capital on their own.
That's his vision.
That's the vision that he
describes the U.S. should be
implementing right now.
What do you make
of that proposal?
Because it was delivered
in Brussels,
and it ruffled a few feathers.
>> Christine Lagarde: Well,
you know, on the point
of making sure that
private capital can invest,
that's exactly what we do.
It is because private capital
has completely lost interest
in certain countries.
You know, when I look at the
three that I've mentioned,
Egypt, Ukraine, Argentina.
Why did we come in?
because nobody else
wanted to come in.
Because there was not a single
investor who was prepared
to take the risk of going
in because the situation was
in disorder, because
public finances were not
properly managed.
Because there were
external factors
that created massive
instability.
So we come in and we
enable the country
to become attractive again.
So it's not as if
we were a substitute
to private sector
investors -- investment.
We are the facilitators
of that investment.
Because otherwise
they won't come.
They simply won't come.
Too risky for them.
Once they know that we are
involved, it means that we put
in place, you know,
debt sustainability.
If restructuring is
needed, we ask for it.
If new monetary policy needs to
be implemented, we recommend it
and it's implemented, with
some success, I dare say.
So I'm not sure that he
understands very clearly what is
-- well, our mission
is prosperity.
And yes, this is what the
initial founders actually tasked
us to do and that's
what we need to do.
>> Margaret Brennan: So these
descriptions of the vision
and the leadership that
America's providing
on this front, for you it is not
achieving what you were saying
is needed to meet the crisis,
right now, that you see.
>> Christine Lagarde:
I was curious
about the taxpayers' money.
Because you know, the --
we've actually always
paid back and more.
So over the course of time,
the United States has actually
made quite a bit of money
out of the IMF involvement
in countries.
>> Margaret Brennan: You think
there's just a fundamental
misunderstanding or
are there portions
of truth to these criticisms?
>> Christine Lagarde: Well,
the fact that growth must
be generated as a result
of our involvement is something
that I completely agree with.
It doesn't come overnight.
Because you need to, you
know, restore the situation.
You need to sort
out public finance.
You need to reorganize
sometimes, you know,
through structural
reforms, the economy.
But growth ultimately
comes back.
When I look at -- I'll tell
you, as French finance minister,
we had to deal with some
difficult cases in Europe.
But when I look at a country
like Portugal, the involvement
of the IMF was critical in
turning the situation around
and sorting out quite
a few difficult issues.
Portugal is now doing
pretty well compared
with other European countries.
When I look at Ireland,
Ireland is thriving.
>> Margaret Brennan: These
are countries that needed --
>> Christine Lagarde: Those are
countries where we had to come
in as the IMF, we had to put
in place significant
lending programs.
And we expected serious
measures to be taken
on the physical front, because
there was too much fiscal
deficit, and because the
-- in the case of Ireland,
because the banking system
was completely out of control
and had gone way too far into
expanding beyond the country.
So you know, these programs
have clearly generated a growth.
>> Margaret Brennan: When you
use that phrase, you know,
describing, we could
live in an age of anger.
You're putting a timeline
out, decades from now.
If you look at some
of the forces,
not just in the United
States, that contributed
to making trade a very
contentious issue during the
2016 campaign, on the
left and on the right,
but also what you're
seeing in Europe,
in your home country
of France right now.
Protests around the economy
and specifically the gas tax.
I won't get into President
Trump's tweet about it tonight.
But generally speaking,
aren't you seeing
those forces of anger.
I mean, you're seeing more
populace governments come
to power or at least use the
economy and anti-insti --
anti-multilateral
institutional rhetoric
in a lot of places right now.
>> Christine Lagarde: Yes.
That is --
>> Margaret Brennan: Are we in
that age that you're describing?
I mean, where are
we as the time --
>> Christine Lagarde: We
are at risk of slipping
into that kind of age of anger.
Which is why it is
critically important
to actually address
those issues.
As I was trying to explain in
my remarks, those are not issues
that can be addressed
purely domestically.
Some of them have to be
addressed domestically.
But when it comes to trade,
to tax, to climate change,
to cybersecurity, to
corruption it has to be
on an international
cooperation basis, as well.
They come together.
But, yes, there has to be
a response to those issues
because many people are not
satisfied with their income,
are not satisfied with their
future, have this anxiety
of what the future holds
for their children and it --
all these concerns
need to be addressed.
Need to be addressed
by societies at large.
>> Margaret Brennan: The
challenge there is that lack
of trust in the institutions
that are tasked with this
or have been tasked with this.
>> Christine Lagarde: Yes.
Yes.
>> Margaret Brennan:
You mentioned your time
when you were Minister
of Finance in France,
and clearly one of the most
difficult time periods you could
have that job.
And I remember from covering
it, that famous story
of you speaking to then
Treasury Secretary Hank Paulson
and advising him against
allowing Lehman Brothers
to go under.
>> Christine Lagarde: Yes.
>> Margaret Brennan: You
foresaw the domino affect.
Did you see -- did
you draw a line
between what you predicted
then and where we are now?
Is that where this shift
began, that you're laying out?
>> Christine Lagarde:
I certainly did not
anticipate that at the time.
But looking back, yes, I
think that there is a lot
in today's anger, resentment,
frustration that is
actually attributable
to the legacy of the crisis.
I think that we did a
reasonably good job in trying
to strengthen the
financial system,
avoid that people actually
lose all their savings,
and that there be bank runs
all over those countries.
But, I think, the fact that
we addressed the issues
of institutions, of the
financial system at large,
without doing probably
enough explanation
as what it meant for people.
And the fact that many involved
in those financial deals
got away with it and managed
to reestablish themselves,
I think,
created a sense of impunity.
In other words, some
of the lower,
middle class people
thinking to themselves, okay,
I've lost my job,
I've lost my house.
And those people,
what have they lost?
Their bonus?
Yes. But that's about it.
And they reestablished
themselves.
So I think this is not at the
root of and the only component
of the frustration and
the anger that we see,
but it certainly
participates and fueling it.
>> Margaret Brennan: So how --
>> Christine Lagarde:
That's what I call the sort
of untold story of the
legacy of the crisis.
>> Margaret Brennan: So how
do you address that then?
If that age of anger
is simmering.
>> Christine Lagarde:
I think it's, you know,
in a way it's too late
to go back to things
that should have taken
place at that time.
But we also have the possibility
with new technologies,
a digital age, that is clearly
in the making at the moment
and at an accelerated pace,
to organize it in such a way
that it is transparent,
that it is accountable,
that it includes people,
that they are brought in to
that digital picture by being
properly trained, educated,
skilled and that they don't
feel there's emasculation
that you have when something is
so alien to you, and so foreign
to you that yet again you
feel that anger about it.
>> Margaret Brennan: You
want another Bretton Woods
type summit?
>> Christine Lagarde: There's so
many groups that are thinking,
oh, let's have another
Bretton Woods.
Let's just reform.
I think it's --
>> Margaret Brennan:
Who leads this?
>> Christine Lagarde: Oh, there
are multiple leaders everywhere.
You know. They don't have
to do the job of, you know,
giving advice, drafting and
preparing those programs,
and providing technical
assistance around the globe
to have an 89 countries.
But the beauty of
the institution
that I have the privilege to
lead, is that in its articles,
in its foundations,
are the seeds
for constant transformation.
What is changing
massively around it calls
for probably a different
approach.
I think, that the digital
economy in which we are moving,
which is transforming
the financial sector,
the existing relationship
between value and monetary cost,
all that needs new thinking.
I think it's more new
thinking than a reform
of the Bretton Woods system.
>> Margaret Brennan: I know
the IMF has written on this
and talked about demand for
cash decreasing and, you know,
money itself is changing,
not just how we think
and talk about this.
You mentioned Phintec in that
context, financial technologies
and all the various forms of it.
I mean, where there
are advantages
and there are disadvantages,
these days it seems
to be not very well understood,
even by the public at large.
How much more of this needs
to be led, not by the IMF
or these organizations, but
coming from the corporate world?
Coming from Silicon Valley?
You have these hearings on
Capital Hill and the joke is,
you know, you have these CEOs
come up and answer questions
and the individuals asking
them don't even know how
to use the websites that
they're talking about.
You know, I mean, how do you
regulate cryptocurrencies?
How do you talk about
all of this in a way
that actually leads to some
kind of regulation or reform?
>> Christine Lagarde:
Well, first of all,
I don't think it should be
entirely left in the hands
of those corporate
sector representatives
or their legal departments
or their public affairs.
Because they are dealing
with a common good.
They're dealing with
your privacy.
They're dealing with your data.
And they're dealing
with your freedom.
So --
So governmental authorities,
Parliamentarians
have to be involved.
And they have to be held
along the way for those
who are not computer literate,
for those who feel
completely alien
to this digital transformation.
They have to be held by --
including my people like us,
the IMF, in relation to
financial technologies.
Because, you know, we try
to grasp what it means,
how its formed, how those
technologies are used
to shorten the circuits
to enable payments
and to include people that
we're not including --
not included in the banking
sector, for instance.
So it is a public
responsibility.
And it has to be done, again, in
cooperation with those engineers
and in cooperation with those
who understand the future
of data protection, who
understands, you know,
how cloud will eventually
be accessible
or be raidable and hackable.
So there are many technicalities
that you don't master,
that I don't master either.
But, you know, having
enough knowledge
to understand the key
principles that need
to be respected is something, I
believe, fall on the shoulders
of Parliamentarians and
members of government
because they today
have the responsibility
to represent the people.
>> Margaret Brennan: You've
also issued a number of calls
for some of those
parliamentarians to get rid
of the legal obstacles
to inclusion of women.
>> Christine Lagarde: Yes.
>> Margaret Brennan:
In the economy.
>> Christine Lagarde: Yes.
>> Margaret Brennan:
Where does that begin?
>> Christine Lagarde: It
very often begins at home.
Of the 189 countries that are
members of the institution,
about 90 percent still
have in their constitution
or in the legal system
discrimination against women,
barriers to the participation in
the economy, to the inheritance
when parents die, to
the owning a business
to the opening bank account,
to be able to bring collateral
when they try to have a loan.
So I think that's where
the work has to begin.
And we have demonstrated
in many countries,
or observed in many
countries such as, you know,
some Latin American
countries like Peru,
some African countries, as well.
That when those changes happen,
it actually has consequences
on the economy and it pushes
growth and it enables women
to become better
integrated into the economy.
But it's not only that.
It begins there because there
should not be legal barriers
and legal constraints imposed by
governments that prevent women
from playing their
role in the economy.
>> Margaret Brennan: How much
of an economic benefit is there?
How do you quantify --
>> Christine Lagarde: Huge.
It's huge.
I mean, it varies
from, you know,
if you look at the
Nordic countries.
You know, Norway being clearly
one of the best performers.
Finland being very
good, as well.
But from those countries to
say, India, Saudi Arabia,
you can have an increase in
the economy, which varies
from 3 percent to 27 percent.
So that's nothing
to be, you know,
sort of turning your eyes away.
It's pretty big.
>> Margaret Brennan:
Why the resistance?
>> Christine Lagarde: Ha.
>> Margaret Brennan: If you can
make the argument on numbers,
why is there is such resistance?
>> Christine Lagarde: I think
you're talking about something
that goes much, much deeper
into culture, into psyche,
into the way in which
societies have been built
over the course of time.
You're also talking
about the divide
between urban centers
and rural areas.
You know, India is a case
in point, where clearly
in rural areas, in
particular, women are prevented
from joining the flow from being
economic partners and sometimes
from having access
to sanitation.
>> Margaret Brennan:
Bigger picture.
I know we're running
out of time here.
I would be remis if I
didn't ask you about Brexit.
And what this -- we're talking
about the forces sort of pulling
at the global order right now.
It's -- that's a rejection
of international organizations
and solidarity there.
Add that in to what you're
seeing here in the U.S. as well,
in terms of that
kind of rejection.
I mean, it sounds like you're
trying to swim upstream.
>> Christine Lagarde:
You know, first of all,
I think that the situation
has changed and is changing
in the U.K. When I look at the
latest polls that was produced,
the shift is now into a
majority of those polled.
Now, you can turn surveys and
polls whichever way you want.
But it seems that
there are more Brits
who would rather
remain than exit.
Sad. Number one.
Number two, I think a lot of
the campaign that took place
at the time, two years ago
now, was geared towards,
watch out the foreigners
are going to take, you know,
your meal away and
they're going to have --
they're going to go first
in the health benefits
and healthcare system.
And they're going to take jobs.
And it was the fear
of the foreigners.
And fortunately,
from within Europe.
And it was directed at people
from Poland, from Bulgaria,
from Romania, who by the way,
have been extremely
well integrated
in say the German economy,
as was demonstrated recently,
in a country that needed
additional skilled labor.
So that fear factor that was
raised during the campaign may
have completely missed
the opportunity
that that particular flow of
migration actually produced
in an economy next
door, which was Germany.
So that's a little
bit beside the point.
But --
I think there is regret in
many, many European corners.
I think there is more
regret in the U.K
than there was only
six months ago.
And I think there is
now, the realization
that there will be more
loss as a result of Brexit
than was ever mentioned,
described, accounted for,
by those who campaigned
for the Brexit.
I can say that with
relative confidence
because when we produced the
article for, for the U.K.,
which is the annual audit
that we do of all economies,
we did actually gave -- we did
give at the time three scenarios
of Brexit, one of which was the
baseline, which was pretty much
in line with what
everybody assumed.
But another one which was
a [inaudible] scenario
which is very close
to some of the numbers
that we are seeing now.
>> Margaret Brennan:
The dark scenario?
>> Christine Lagarde: In
terms of forecast coming up.
In case of a Brexit development
and in case of a no-deal Brexit,
which is what we had considered.
>> Margaret Brennan: Is that
a warning to brace ourselves?
>> Christine Lagarde: I think
it was a very clear, you know,
assessment of what the
consequences would be
as a result of a no-deal Brexit
scenario, where the terms
of trade between the U.K.
and its main economic
and trade partner, which is the
European Union would be done
under the WTO rules with
no additional sweetener
to WTO rules.
>> Margaret Brennan: Wow.
The dark scenario, is a
scary phrase to end on.
But, unfortunately,
I'm told that we are --
>> Christine Lagarde: Oh, no.
But you know there was something
very interesting today,
which is the attorney
general opinion delivered
to the European Court
of Justice.
So for those like me who would
very much like to keep the U.K.
within the European Union,
there is apparently a perfectly,
legally acceptable way
to revoke the article 50,
which is the provision under
which the U.K. pulled out.
>> Margaret Brennan: You think
that's a viable scenario?
>> Christine Lagarde: It's
-- at least it's legal.
I'm a reformed lawyer.
[ Laughter ]
>> Margaret Brennan: I
think this is the optimist
that you described yourself as.
>> Christine Lagarde: Yes, yes.
>> Margaret Brennan: Thank
you so much, Madame Lagarde.
>> Christine Lagarde: Thank you.
>> Margaret Brennan:
Thanks all of you.
[ Applause ]